we're moving into part two now i don't
need to prove this anymore they're
proven
okay now in part two what they want is
for us to write a quadratic equation any
quadratic equation
that has these twos and the roots okay
so
when you have a look at these results if
these are the roots
then this should be equal to this is the
sum of the roots
minus b on a and this is the product of
the roots c on a
now they say write any quadratic
equation right
so being that um i can pick whatever
leading coefficient i like i can pick
any value of a
that i like i can just make a one like
why not right
so if i make this one then it's just
that
and if i make this one it's just that
okay
so now i know what the coefficients are
b should be 1 c should be 2 and i
already said a
i just made that one okay so my
coefficients will give me this x
squared there's my 1 plus um
x because because my b is equal to one
plus two
there we go okay so then
uh we are asked to where are we asked to
go from that we want
actual values for for these roots yeah
okay
so you're like okay i know how to get
values out of roots i just take the
quadratic formula
right and i say x equals and then i just
turn through the formula okay
so i should get minus b plus or minus
the square root of
b squared one yeah minus eight
four ac so that's going to be negative
seven under there which is of course
what you're
expecting um over 2a so then you take
out your factor of i
and then you pause okay now at this
point i have two solutions to this right
now the question is very very clever in
that
it knows one of these will be theta and
one of them will be fine
but then it's like well which one's
which and it actually specifies for you
which ones which
most people would just say you know
usually we're like oh one's alpha
one's beta who cares which ones which it
doesn't matter once the first one was
the second one
no big u but we actually do know things
about
theta and phi they are not arbitrary
they're these guys
yeah okay so we know things about them
um we know that if i if i write these
out as the two solutions
okay what's the difference between them
i should
have um minus a half
minus i root 7 on 2
or minus a half plus
i written 7 on 2. okay so what we need
to think about
is look the real parts of these are the
same the difference between these two
solutions is
the imaginary part of this one is
negative and the imaginary part of this
one is positive
okay so you come back to these and you
think is there anything about
what i know about these that will tell
me
um that it should be that the imaginary
part should be positive
or negative hmm
now i want you to think about it for a
second because um
this is where this is where the powers
actually become significant
okay the powers become significant
so just look at where they are in the
diagram and like
add them together ah okay right so when
you have a look at
so here's my here's my kind of shoddy
looking diagram um but you do have i do
have seven
branches okay um now is it accurate
enough see 2.7
i don't think it is accurate enough um
i'm just thinking four should take me
half halfway
oh yeah it'll be okay i think it'll be
all right we said there's one longer
okay so so yeah roughly speaking roughly
speaking
let's have a think about theta okay so
when you
multiply complex numbers you rotate
around and round and round when you add
complex numbers
what does that mean
yeah that's right that's exactly right
they're just vectors they're just
vectors okay
so let's think about where these vectors
are okay alpha
to the power of one roughly speaking is
about here
there's alpha roughly okay alpha squared
will be somewhere up here
okay where's after the power of four
it'll be it should be this one roughly
okay when you want to think about it
um how many alphas will take me exactly
halfway around and the answer is three
and a half
right that will if if seven alphas will
take me all
the way around three and a half alphas
will take me right to here
so the fourth one should be just a bit
after okay so this one here
is roughly alpha and the power of seven
now when you add these vectors think
about what's happening
okay where do you end up so for instance
i go alpha
and then i go alpha squared i'll be
somewhere up here and then i'll go
alpha to the power so it should be four
four right so i'm i'm somewhere
here okay right now here's the important
thing though can you see what's going on
where do i end up and what's the
difference between these two
i'm clearly clearly on the imaginary
axis i'm positive
right so that's how you know okay this
guy this guy has
the imaginary part of theta right
that ought to be positive because of
where the vectors lead you
and in exactly the same way but opposite
alpha to the power of 5 is somewhere
around here and alpha 6 is down here
so if you look at this one you'll end up
with the imagine part being negative
okay so that's all the logic
how do you set it up right so that's
right so you say
i would say note that okay um
theta is that whoops
plus this okay so therefore
the imaginary part of theta is
now what is it well you use your you go
back to your cis notation okay so
the the way i get the imaginary
component is by taking the sine
of all of the angles two pi on seven
um four pi on seven eight pi on seven
of all of these different pieces right
because because of course you know it's
because theta plus i
oops sine theta right so all your
imaginary parts
are sine of whatever your angles are i
suppose i should have said alpha
okay alpha alpha so here's the imaginary
part up here
and here's the real part over here okay
so what is the imaginary part well it's
going to be sine of
this angle right two pi on seven that's
one
around um sine of four pi
on seven that's two and then the last
one is eight pi on seven
because it's four lines okay so i've got
this
right but i know that um that's i
i made my logic through my vectors right
um i can say
but the imaginary part theta
is greater than zero right so therefore
it's going to be
this solution down here therefore theta
equals
this one plus plus
um i have root 7 on 2 only
can't be the other one right
ok right so so therefore i'm i'm
excluded this once we did it that must
be fine
okay so that's how i logic that out now
why did i bother writing all of this out
okay
um it was to draw attention to the next
part part three
part three they bring in some causes
you're like if you're if you don't write
this down
and you're not thinking through this
this logic you're like where do causes
come from right
but the answer is really obvious the
causes come from considering the real
part
of the equation okay so you have a look
at this
you're like um the real part for both of
these
roots theta and phi is negative a half
like negative half oh that's suspicious
right
so you can say the real part of
it's the same right theta and phi they
both have the same real component but we
might as well just write three because
i've already been thinking about theta
the real component of theta will because
of all of these angles
okay because of all of these angles cos
2.7
cos five four pi on seven um cos
eight pi on seven right now that oh
that's really close to what they want us
to prove except
this thing is off right but that's okay
that could be fixed right i can use trig
identities for that okay
so i can say but i'm going to make two
statements okay first i know what the
real component of theta is
it is negative a half
okay and secondly i can make i can draw
some conclusions from this
so cos of 8 pi on 7
that's equal to cos of pi plus
pi on seven okay and the identity there
i think that's minus
that's negative cos 0.17
and even if you don't remember that you
can kind of
deduce from what you're required to
prove and what you already know
which is this that it must be if you if
you're that bad and under pressure and
try
trying to remember which way does it go
you can use that
diagram and then yeah yeah that's right
you can you can just draw yeah
that works fine so on the basis of this
which i'm going to substitute here
and this which i'm going to here that's
the result you need
cos 2 pi on 7 cos 4.7
minus and it's equal to negative
a half which is which is astonishing
when you think about it
because if you look at this line right
it's all it's all just angles and like
exact values but how did we get there
through some
random complex number rubbish with
imaginary numbers
none of which appear here which is
really interesting